I just don't condone the bashing of Dak
Prescott and the Dallas Cowboys and have
the same energy for the Eagles we want
the same energy for everybody cuz
there's a whole bunch of bashing when
it's Dak Prescott but not the say when
it's the Eagles I got time today a lot
of people said the Browns defense was
overhyped I said the Browns are the real
deal AO said this which pissed me off
I'm not worried about the 49ers they
were missing Christian mcaffrey Debo
Samuel the Browns were missing Deshawn
Watson Nick chub they were missing them
key factors before the game even started
so why is it that we are just scrubs and
we're nobodies that don't deserve to be
on the field and we're just all talk but
there's a 100 excuses for these other
these other teams if y'all just going to
hate Cowboys Nation just say y'all hate
Cowboys Nation I'm tired of people
trashing my quarterback I'm tired of
people trashing my team and that's why I
had nothing to say to the me this week
you want to hear me talk come hear me
talk on the edge Monday night and that's
Point Blank period